so that was um different big finish time
on Doctor Who because here on council of
geeks every single Sunday we do Doctor
Who which apparently even though it's
been that way for a while now people
when I point that out I feel like oh I
hadn't even noticed so I'm gonna start
pointing that out more regularly but
yeah master so this is a Big Finish
story selected by my supporters on
patreon thank you guys um so how de boy
how do you even talk about this one it's
different and like I do a Big Finish I'm
gonna go spoiler free for as long as I
can and then eventually I'll have to get
into spoilers for some of the stuff I'm
going to talk about but yeah it's funny
I feel like in many ways the title of
the thing is a spoiler or or it could
have been if if it was more poorly
written because it's it's very very
low-key there's a framing device of the
doctor relaying a story to a guy who's
getting ready to assassinate somebody
and the story being told within that
framing device is about basically three
people then the doctor shows up and then
it's four and then like and another one
who kind of comes in and out but it's
it's really it's a it's a really small
story and it deals with these people in
this town and there's a guy who is the
village doctor basically uh goes by John
Smith
he doesn't have memory prior to 10 years
ago when he first showed up in the town
he has scars on his face that looked
like he was burned and he's having his
birthday it's not his real birthday he
doesn't remember his birthday but it's
the anniversary of when he showed up and
he celebrating it with his closest
friends this married couple and it's
them talking about their relationship
and their history and diverging into
philosophical tangents every now and
then and then the doctor shows up but
that doesn't massively change the
structure of the story it's still
largely just these conversations about
their lives their fears their concerns
the thing the thoughts that poke at
their mind when they're laying in bed
trying to fall asleep kind of thing and
it's honestly it bears more resemblance
to like 40s or 50s era haunted house
story than anything else it bears more
resemblance to like the haunting then it
does to Doctor Who and that's not
necessarily a bad thing it is different
though it's it's very different and I
say that largely in terms of its
structure and its its overall approach
the the doctor featured in this one is
7th doctor Sylvester McCoy and so we've
got basically kind of the edge here
doctor in this particular story and
obviously the master comes into play in
this eventually I don't want to say how
like I said if the title of the thing
wasn't master I would consider even
saying that he's in this to be a spoiler
of sorts but it is the title so I might
as well
and we have Jeffery beavers returning to
the part who played the master innkeeper
of Crockett he was the deformed
[Music]
desiccated version of the master who
basically possessed tree MMus and turned
into Anthony Ainley who played the part
for the remainder of the the classic who
run and he does good work with what he's
doing here and we get various sides and
elements to the master but you're very
size n elements to the doctor and
because we're really only sticking with
this core really tiny group of people we
get to know them really well as as well
and they feel very fleshed out very
lived it and their interactions feel
very genuine you know there's some of
the normal sort of dialog contrivances
that you get where that are just the
nature of the beast with these audio
stories stories in terms of you know
getting information across to the
listener or describing something that
normally they would just be looking at
and not actively describing so I mean
that's just the the nature of the beast
with these things so you need to accept
that going in overall I did like it
I did enjoy it I found it intriguing and
I found most of it by myself going where
is this going and I did find it to be an
interesting journey there are certain
elements about the last episode because
if you don't already know if you're
watching this review and aren't already
a Big Finish listener these things are
broken up into four mini parts there's
structure like classic who episodes so
it's basically about two hours broken
into four parts
complete with intro and outro music each
time era specific to the seventh doctor
natch so in the fourth episode the
fourth section of it there are certain
specifics to what is going on that I'm
kind of iffy on I've taken in a vacuum
they work narrative ly they work but
when I try and place some of the stuff
that's going on here in the greater
context of Doctor Who as a whole it
doesn't quite work for me and I'm not
and I'm not talking continuity I'm just
talking about some of the specific ideas
that are that are present in the tail
end of this I'm kinda like and they're
not things that I inherently think don't
work they're just things that I'm not
sure work in Doctor Who and I can't
explain that more until I get in
spoilers so I'm trying to think if
there's anything else I want to mention
other performances are good supporting
cast is good there
besides Jeffery beavers and Sylvester
McCoy there's really only three other
people in the cast I think there's maybe
a couple of other people as well because
you get like disembodied voices
whispering like I said it bears more
resemblance to a haunted house movie
than anything else and yeah I think I
need to start getting to spoilers so it
was good it was different
I made me appreciate Jeffery beavers
playing the master more than I already
did because I actually think he was one
of the better masters of the classic era
when it came to short stints definitely
a heck of a lot better than I I can't
even remember the guys name now who's
stuck behind that locked off mask in the
deadly assassin but no beavers is good
he saw it so I gotta get into spoilers
now so and you're still here that's your
warning three two one this whole idea of
a personification of death like the
abstract concept of death having
physical form having desires having an
agent
in the master I mean I'll continue to
mow it over but right now at the time of
recording I don't think I can go there
and I think it's just I think it's just
a touch too abstract because and and
sort of like I alluded to I don't have
an inherent problem with the idea of
debt having a personification in fact
there are some personifications of death
in various forms of fiction that I love
Neil Gaiman's death awesome duh the
Marvel personification of death yeah
honestly isn't much of a character a lot
of the time but has been used really
interestingly at a few points are like
I'm totally cool with the concept in
general but Doctor Who at least to me
doesn't feel like the kind of universe
that that sort of thing works in I mean
that entire idea is a just a tad too
ethereal and I mean the doctor can canon
has dealt with you know personifications
of gods effectively but it has found a
way to ground them in the reality of
Doctor Who so you know you can give us
an Egyptian god but you give us Doctor
Who context for it in something like
pyramid of Mars but to have something be
identified as just being death with no
other explanation as to what it is I
just can't I can't quite get there like
I think the closest to something like
that that's in Doctor Who that I that I
would accept would be something like the
black Guardian the white Guardian
because those are fairly abstract broad
concepts but they're also not especially
well defined which I honestly think is
to its benefit it allows basically for
more wiggle room for me to wrap my head
around it in a way it makes it work for
me I have seen other personifications of
death
I understand the concept of death
personified i unders that so that that
sort of inhibits too many restrictions
on to what that idea is and that idea
doesn't fit Doctor Who or at least it
doesn't as as I understand Doctor Who to
be maybe it works for other people maybe
other people don't even question at all
but just have the whole idea of death
being this thing that has been following
the doctor and and is cutting deals with
people like that's just in concept cool
awesome cool stuff fits the whole motif
motif and theme and vibe with a story no
issues but how do you be doctors
specifically it's just not know some of
the other stuff in there it's kind of
interesting like it's so moving off of
my issues with that some of the things
they do with it
assuming you can swallow that concept
which like I said ah I can't mind maybe
maybe later on I'll be able to square
that circle right now I can't but you
know the whole idea of the doctor
actually having crossed a line when he
was very young and I which is what I
think makes it okay you deal with him as
a child and you know what kids do rash
things they do stupid things they don't
understand the consequences of actions
they take or choices that they make not
fully and so the idea of the doctor
having killed their young bully and then
basically offering up the master to
death to be deaths champion because he
was too scared to face that consequence
himself is an interesting idea and it's
interesting in how it attributes the
doctors inherent guilt and reluctance to
ever
allow the master to die that's not to
say that he never has but he's he's
always been reluctant I mean the doctor
is fairly nonviolent regardless but you
know depending on circumstances he will
orchestrate things that will result in
the death of the villains and he doesn't
do that to the master and and this this
does offer an explanation as to why that
might be in it and it is a form of guilt
and that is an interesting take it's one
that I'm probably not gonna take on
board in my own head Canon speaking
personally but points for trying and you
know setting the viability of that idea
aside it is well executed as a concept
and it's well performed and there's some
nifty stuff done but the voices and yeah
it's it is well made it's just that one
element of the core concept that I can't
quite get with so it ends up being one
of those things where I'm not sure that
was a good idea that's a pretty good
execution of that not particularly good
idea which is you know I guess for a
point of comparison that's how I feel
about something like say red dwarf back
to earth which I think it you know
wasn't a good idea but was well executed
comicbooks putting Barbara Gordon back
on her feet getting her out of the
wheelchair when they kicked off to 52 I
think that was a bad idea but at least
in the initial run of it was well
executed so you know every now and then
I run into these things were like that's
just a bad idea I'll never stop thinking
that's a bad idea
but that's still a good execution of
that bad idea and this kind of I think
this I think that's where I land on this
one at least as of recording I I really
do have to kind of sleep on this a bit
more which I suppose begs the question
why didn't you sleep on and then record
the thing because I would have run the
risk of waking up in the morning and not
only not having my feelings change but
also not having my other thoughts as
front in my mind so that's the dice I'm
rolling so yeah Big Finish
master have you heard it what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it do you want to help
decide what Big Finish
stories I will listen to or what classic
Doctor Who stories I will tackle next
well you can support me on patreon at
any level you get to take part in those
polls to help guide the channel as well
as you know help me with stuff and make
the whole thing better hopefully also on
Twitter you can email me I sell t-shirts
bla bla bla bla bla links for all that
stuff is down in the description so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]